e da tutti ragazzi minuti questo video
sono parigi oggi stiamo con ciccio è
pietro e basta
ciao amici allora voi non conoscete
questo gioco io neanche neanche loro
però sia di escape istriani tv prison
break e scappi da una prigione e
fortissimo questo ciò che è bellissimo
noi ci siamo già riusciti paolo dio e
ciccio scappare da una prigione questa
sera per la seconda volta in cui ci
muoviamo però qualcuno che è vero è
finita male mi piace però dimentica chi
c'è adesso stai tranquillo non ti
prendere vendette vabbè allora come tu
sei molto abituato leva su tradimenti
metti of sex scegli il tuo personaggio
aspetta che io prima scelgo le cose e
poi vi invito al mio personaggio è some
cioè il mio cane come personaggio
scegliamo il mio cane allora io posso
uscire dalla mia cella quindi possono
tra noi non posso uscire al cielo come
la pace lascia aperta a roma sono gli
altri che stanno evadendo ci sono altre
persone che ha detto all'evasione ai
anno ci sono i cani che mi picchia non
ho capito cosa è successo e da mandare
in isolamento sono d'accordo ragazzi
stanno mandando in isolamento
anche a me ha ucciso un cane allora sono
uscito dalla cella è partita la si è
capito mai a scena aperta a tutti coloro
assente siamo noi tre ti siamo capito il
nostro obiettivo è quello di uscire di
prigione capitolo cioè non è che
dobbiamo fare cagate che di un mini poso
siamo usciti bruciamo a lei che mi vedi
che mi ha fatto uscire vedi come se
uscito non lo so anche te vieni che ti
ha fatto uscire cavani se lo merita
cosa vuol dire non ho capito acquistati
sembra più la mia subito a scuola questo
è un poi cliccate la mappa in alto a
destra c'è veramente tante cosa fa il
senso allora c'è un punto esclamativo
che sta camminando e si aspettava da
poter scavare lo vediamo cosa dice va
bene ha quindi la freccia dice sempre
dove devi andare
dolce che bello essere detenuti che
fanno le cose che fanno tutte le cose
belle
cena a cena a cena veloci mangiare e
mangiare si mangia più amore meno bolle
più amore meno botte cena cena si cena
tutti toni io voglia fare amicizia con
toni come si parla con toni ha poi
prenderemo di prendere la menzione e non
importa va affatto bene allora prendiamo
robe tipo il cibo per haga che vuol bene
facciamo veramente schifo questo
mangiando l'analogia ci sono tutte sono
svenuto in questo mezzo temponi per mano
l'ho mangiato io e niente ero maggiore
tempo libero allora nel tempo libero
in teoria lo scopo di questo gioco è
quello di mettere via degli oggetti per
poi evadere giusto con il tempo libero
dovremo sfruttare per fare le cose
giuste
no per evadere cioè dove trovare oggetti
per evadere
io grazie dovendo un tubetto di pittura
io ho un calzino ma chi ragazzi per
evadere compenso calzino tubetto della
forma infatti come facciamo ad evadere
larga come facciamo trovare le cose a
corteggiare una certa persona ma non
funziona è il momento di mettere il
turbo procurati una cosa vestiti da
medico alla svelta vabbè mi procuro
vestiti da medico
io vi procura vestiti da medico voi
procuratevi delle robe fate qualcosa
praga sta finendo il tempo libero
appello appello appello ai a porco che
insieme a me e ai picchiato nella
guardia venute meno io sono qua fermo ma
mi segue la guardi aiuto a vicenda mi
segue questa tesa ma io
non parlo parlo no scusate scusate non
volevo meno male il resto sono
tranquillo perche seguita traguardi
guardi un detenuto ha posto la ritorno
in sella grazie 5 grazie cioè salvato la
vita a tutti e due
c'è anche il tempo per regione ce la
vuole la macello noi con l'osso altra
pedina tenute potremo uscire volendo
possiamo uscire vediamo e a me non mi fa
uscire prima come ho fatto a pila
pallone che sto facendo riposare a
perché ti puoi prendere lenzuole fare un
film con manichino e vedremo posto tuo
ho capito devo dormire come faccio male
e lo deve riposizionare le stelle risate
siamo a metà stella non facciamo carico
fece niente
appello proseguito ancora lorenzo più
dream pazzesco ma dobbiamo farlo appello
quindi buongiorno buongiorno ragazzi
nell'anno conta le celle che verranno
controllate di oggi sono averi europea
perché a randomicamente controllano le
celle quindi gli oggetti per per fuggire
non dobbiamo inserirli nelle nostre
celle ceo dobbiamo nasconderli bene sono
amici per pd e colorazione colazione e
coazione e colazione buongiorno per
evadere dobbiamo usare degli strumenti e
fin qua ok per fin qua ci siete allora
aspetta troppo tavoli andare nel mio
tavolo e il mio tavolo io adesso di
convincere la andiamo a dormire quando
ci sveglieremo e vedremo ve lo prometto
seguitemi parole seguite anno da dormire
allora gli siamo guardate il contenuto
del tavolo potete trovare delle cose
fatte ho visto che un oggetto in
particolare che non saldate a dormire
dice la gente in particolare che non so
come si chiama però so come l'icona che
serve per fuggire è un'icona per scavare
uno scalpello
nell'appello si famigliare ducati lo
scompartimento segreto se come lei tra
questi c'è il lunotto ed adrenalina ah
no però non c'è secondo a priori eccolo
esatto tali ma vediamo se funziona la
bbc trinity seguitemi
ma no fermo la cena è bello appello all
appello metto via la linea sono un
casino ciò calzino in mano il calzino
dovrebbe essere un problema
allora io ho visto l'ultima volta l'ho
visto quel film dove lati scappavano
quindi noi adesso scappiamo né ci
picchiano valutare le cose dello smalto
protesta la bottiglia del dopobarba
aspettano
venite raga seguitemi
forse dobbiamo operare ti seguo mentre
dopo che vi operano e shin attimo che
andiamo a fuggire
venite uscite seguitemi ma c'è una marca
che poteva passare parliamo parliamo tra
di noi prima di lei la bella una
giornata bella bella
abbiamo ok fermi tutti i siti porco
demonio porco rischio spaccatura lo sta
sbarcando a devi spaccare spacca lo
spaccato con l'anima abbiamo bisogno di
un'altra anima ho fatto il più credito
c'è un buchino adesso ho fatto un
pochino mi hanno portato in isolamento
tempo libero abbiamo cinque stelle
regala cinque sono in isolamento
ciao amici aveva allora niente troviamo
un'altra lima trova un'altra lì ma tu
che sei fuori veloce trova tra lima ma
tu perché si in isolamento ciccio che
hai fatto
[Risate]
io domani privato cioè ciccio che è
infatti in italia
vado in isolamento perché ho fatto
tentato di evadere e c'è il cice isola
verde che ci faccia non ho fatto niente
ma ce l'ho ce l'ho c'è un'altra lima
ciccio trovare altra lì ma ti prego
aiuti il problema è che mentre tu e va
di là la parete elettrificata quindi ti
prendi del danno come tagliate sul
partito knock down si fa come poi come
fai con tasto x6 non sai che scelga il
film conta scusa via via sponda di
numeri non morire sui muri sono fuggite
volete come si fa come sono tasse usa il
tasto usa da me no fuori mai fare vai
vai vai a portata medaille fuggite voi
fuggite da farsi non fuggono cavolo
stavamo tagliando il recinto eravamo lì
arriva da perdiamo ragazzi adesso adesso
un problema ma costa 40 guarda quante
quante rotto poi avete bucato di fianco
non dovevo capire quello che eravamo lì
rega se riusciamo a prima che se ne
accorgono e non se ne sono ancora
accorti ma vogliamo tipo fregarci nel
pranzo cucina m dove la troviamo si è
però dove la troviamo in giro siamo in
tre e proveremo la libera qualche parte
ma ho trovato a due o tre tutti e due ma
sopra saprai mai ciccio prendi la ciccio
però se sarà perché 25 in a portà
tuttavia buttato un ora li ha portati
selvatici porca vacca 10 per cento dai
dove diavolo se vado servi dai ragazzi
danni riparati li mortacci porco demonio
porco i ragazzi di escape facciamo
schifo abbiamo mai giocato nel secondo
episodio problema veramente ad evadere
per adesso ci abbiamo provato niente
male niente ma è andata male però vabbè
però che vi sia piaciuto ma se il
momento mi piace anche la descrizione
sono salve rischiate
[Musica]